NARRATOR: In 1933, Adolf
Hitler rose to power
and began consolidating
Germany's military, political,
and economic institutions
under the control
of his Nazi party apparatus.
For years, Wernher
von Braun avoided
becoming a member
of the Nazi party,
but on November 12, 1937, he was
commanded to join, and did so.
To hear him tell it, he was--
had no choice, that
he-- it was either
do that or face the same fate
as everyone else who disobeyed
the Nazis, certain death.
Von Braun didn't think the Nazi
movement was the way to go,
but it was a means to an
end to develop his rockets.
NARRATOR: In 1944, with the
help of additional funding from
the German government, von
Braun launched the 45-foot,
27,000-pound A4, later
rechristened the V2,
or Vengeance Weapon.
ROBERT PEARLMAN:
The V2 rocket was
a one-stage liquid-fueled
rocket that was not
comparable to any other
rocket at the time,
because there weren't
other rockets at the time.
You had rockets in development.
What von Braun was
able to do with the V2
was combine the theory with
the practical application,
and develop the first rocket
ever to be able to reach space.
NARRATOR: How was von
Braun able to advance
Germany's rocket program so
far in just a few short years?
Was it due to a desperate
nation supplying him
with massive amounts
of money and material?
Or could there be
another reason?
On July 1, 1935, Hitler's SS
commander, Heinrich Himmler,
established Ahnenerbe, an elite
Nazi institute that purported
to research the cultural
and archaeological history
of the Germans.
However, its true purpose
proved far more bizarre.
MIKE BARA: Ahnenerbe
was based on the idea
that the Aryan race was
the most directly descended
from ancient,
perhaps alien, gods.
DAVID CHILDRESS:
Part of their job
was to literally go all over the
world looking for special cult
artifacts, things like
the Ark of the Covenant
and the Holy Grail.
MIKE BARA: Von Braun became
closely associated with them
through his association with the
SS and with Heinrich Himmler.
And one of the main reasons
for that was that they felt
like rocketry was
almost an arcane secret,
a sort of black magic
that would enable
them to dominate the world.
NARRATOR: As World War II
broke out across Europe,
Ahnenerbe expanded its research
into secret weapons programs,
and Himmler tapped von Braun
as its technical director
at Germany's
large-scale experimental
research facility at Peenem nde
in northwest Germany.
It was during these
next several years
that von Braun advanced
the science of propulsion,
aerodynamics, and rocket
guidance systems beyond what
anyone had thought possible.
DAVID CHILDRESS: You
have to ask yourself,
where would they have gotten
that kind of knowledge
so quickly?
One of the possible reasons
is that the Ahnenerbe,
with their researchers, had
actually discovered technology
through some of
their expeditions
to find ancient relics,
and their search, really,
for ancient technology.
NARRATOR: Is it possible
that the Ahnenerbe
discovered artifacts
that helped them
advance their weapons research?
Some ancient astronaut theorists
suggest that the Nazis did,
in fact, recover something.
Not from the ancient world, but
from an extraterrestrial one.
A multicolored orb of light
was seen in the sky in 1937
in southwestern Poland.
And by all accounts,
this was a UFO sighting.
But it's a lot more than that.
This orb actually
crashed into the ground.
NARRATOR: According to the
account, when investigators
reached the
suspected crash site,
they found a strange
disk-shaped object.
Nazi officials are said to
have taken the damaged craft
to a nearby secure facility,
where it was examined
by Germany's top
aeronautical experts,
including Wernher von Braun.
While no remains of any
alleged UFOs survived the war,
German engineers
did develop a series
of revolutionary
aircraft, including
the first rocket-powered jet
fighter, the first stealth
bomber, and even
anti-gravity-powered
saucer-shaped vehicles.
From what we're
able to glean today,
Nazi technology at the
end of World War II
was so advanced that
they had things that are
still science fiction today.
Anti-gravity, beam
weapons, flying
saucers, flying
triangles, things that
are still kept secret today.